to the u.s now where president joe biden
is uh feeling the heat from rising
inflation and it seems to have shortened
his temper biden sarcastically lashed
out at a news reporter who asked if
rising prices were a political problem
for him
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid sound a little bit
all right let's go right to our
washington bureau chief ines bowl for
more on this story hi enos you know
president biden has been known in the
past to be prone to outbursts and and
gaffes but this remark really has
sparked a lot of controversy so tell us
more what's been happening
yeah right i mean biden as you just said
sumi has had such dropouts throughout
his long career but after that
disastrous press conference last week
and now getting caught on that hot mike
moment some people here really raise the
question if he's still fit for office i
mean especially giving the immense
stresses under not only domestically but
also internationally with the pending
ukraine conflict that definitely needs a
fit
american commander-in-chief
what do you think this outburst in
particular tells us about how things are
looking for his presidency right now
well we are watching a presidency that
is having an extremely difficult time
finding its footage i mean
attempting the balancing act of dealing
with the political reality stateside and
deal with these tremendous
challenges across the at the atlantic so
it seems basically each day president
biden has to put out fires in places
where many political observers did not
expect to see russia afghanistan
and an unstable economy so this is
really putting this administration to
the brink yeah we know that inflation is
such a hot button issue in the us right
now with his approval rating suffering
and the democrats also as a party
struggling to get anything passed how do
things look for the midterms coming up
in november
right sumi historically the party in
charge always loses its power after the
midterms but this time the democrats are
expected to lose not just the majority
in the senate but even in the house that
essentially leaves the president in a
powerless position to govern and on top
of that you just
mentioned that the divide between the
progressives and the moderates of his
own party is also much bigger
than he and others expected so when the
midterms midterms will come later in
november this year it will be extremely
difficult for the democrats to ask the
americans
to put them back in charge when they
believe nothing has been passed also
because of the internal fighting within
the democratic party
our washington bureau chief inez poll
thank you so much
you